Hello everyone.
We will start now with our
second set of panelists.
They told me--
each of them came up to me
independently actually and said,
"Well, we heard part of the first panel
and I feel like we're going
to be a little bit redundant."
But as I told them
you will hear their insights
through a different set of lenses
and a different set of perspectives
as tenured faculty.
These three distinguished faculty
have contributed a great deal
to this institution, but only to--
also to their fields.
And I will introduce them in the order
in which they will be speaking
and they will each have
ten minutes for remarks
and we hope plenty of time
for questions at the end.
Gary King, to my immediate right,
is the newly Albert J. Weatherhead III
University Professor
at Harvard University.
As you may know,
university professors are
unique here at Harvard.
There are only 22 such titles,
and Gary King
is an individual who
well deserves it.
He is presently based
in the Department of Government in
the Faculty of Arts and Sciences
and serves as Director of the Institute
for Quantitative Social Science.
Dr. King develops and applies
empirical methods
in many areas of social
science research
focusing on innovations
that span the range
from statistical theory
to practical application.
Gary has been elected fellow of the
American Statistical Association.
Fellow of the American Association
for the Advancement of Science,
Fellow of the American
Academy of Arts and Sciences;
Fellow of the Society
for Political Methodology,
the fellow of the American Academy
Political and Social Sciences,
and President of the Society for
Political Methodology,
and Vice President of the American
Political Science Association.
He has done a great
deal of service to,
not just the Harvard community,
but to his profession.
Dr. King received his B.A.
from SUNY New Paltz
and his PhD. from the
University of Wisconsin, Madison.
Professor Michele Lamont
is the Robert I. Goldman
professor of European Studies
and Professor of
Sociology and of African
and African American studies,
as well as the Senior
Advisor on Faculty Development
and Diversity for the Faculty
of Arts and Sciences.
Dr. Lamont is a fellow of the Canadian
Institute for Advanced Research
and is the co-director of its research
program on successful societies.
Michele's scholarly interests
center on shared concepts
of worth and their
impact on hierarchies
in a number
of social domains.
She has written on how
culture contributes to ethno-racial
and class inequality
and on the evaluation of
excellence in higher education.
She was born in
Toronto and received her B.A.
and her Masters in Political
Theory at Ottawa University,
before pursuing her doctoral
research in sociology
at the University of Paris
where she graduated in 1983.
She held a post-doctoral
fellowship at Stanford University
and took her first faculty position
at the University of Texas, Austin;
soon after leaving
for Princeton University
where she was granted
tenure there in 1993
and to the rank of
full professor in 2000.
We were very privileged
and certainly honored
that she and her husband
came here to Harvard
University in 2003
where she was appointed
Robert I. Goldman Professor
of European Studies in 2006.
She,
as some of you may know,
is the partner of Frank Dobbin
also in the Department of Sociology
and they have three children:
Gabriel, Pierre, and Chloe.
And finally,
Professor David Thomas is the
H. Naylor Fitzhugh Professor
of Business Administration,
as well as being the unit head
in Organizational Behavior at
the Harvard Business School.
He joined the HBS faculty in 1990
and became a tenured
professor in 1998.
From 2005 to 2008,
he served as Senior Associate Dean
and Director of Faculty Recruitment.
David is a recognized thought leader
in the area of strategic
human resource management.
His research addresses issues
related to executive development,
cultural diversity and organizations,
leadership and organizational change.
His book Breaking Through:
The Making of Minority Executives
in Corporate America
has met with critical acclaim and
reviews by academics and journalists,
and is the recipient of the
Academy of Management's
George R. Terry Book Award
for outstanding contribution
to the advancement of
management knowledge.
Professor Thomas received
his Bachelor of Arts,
his Master of Philosophy,
and his Doctor of Philosophy Degrees
from Yale University.
He also holds a Master of
Arts in Organizational Psychology
from Columbia University.
Actually, the three of us
would appreciate it
if you just keep going
on for a while.
[Laughter]
You could just tell tales.
I heard the last panel
said something about
the lack of ego involvement.
[Laughter]
Okay. So I have three
things I want to say.
The first one is
that you should ignore
what we have to say.
And the reason why
is that being an academic
involves cutting your own path.
And so if you did exactly
what the three of us-what any
one of the three of us did,
well, we already did it
so you wouldn't get as
much credit for it.
So, you know,
take the advice that we have as,
you know, good guesses but
you need to do it yourself.
I mean your goal is the creation,
dissemination, and preservation of knowledge
so that's my summary of
what the University is about.
And so go find something
in one of those categories
and come back and show us.
But remember, I mean,
there's more academics
within walking distance
of where we're sitting now
than at any place on the planet
in the history of the world.
I mean it's an
extraordinary place.
Not only do your folks…
Not only are your
folks really happy that
they have a Professor at Harvard,
but actually it's
really cool to be here.
I mean if you
eliminated all the faculty
and students from this place,
like all the faculty and students,
this would still be a
spectacular place.
It would still have the
best collection of minds
that you'd see almost anywhere.
And then if you eliminated
all the rest of the people at Harvard,
we have second-rate
universities
like M.I.T. [Laughter]
around the corner.
I mean it's extra…
it's really extraordinary.
Harvard is an enormous…
even just Harvard is
an enormous place.
So go out and take
advantage of it.
You could spend the next
10 or 20 or 50 years
in your office - hopefully 50 years -
in your office not seeing anybody.
But go out and find people
in other parts of the University.
It's not that hard.
You know, doing things that
you don't know anything about
that you could bring
in ideas to your field.
It's a really great thing.
So anyway,
ignore what I have to say
except all the things I say.
So the second point is,
a little closer to the topic is that
you're now a public figure, okay?
So this is really like going
from a graduate student
to being a faculty.
This is really something to get used to.
So just like a politician
or a movie star,
you're a public figure.
Not as many people are
going to listen to you sing
but you really are a public figure.
In other words,
you have an audience
that's much larger
than you could know
on a one-on-one basis, okay?
So, you know, be public.
Get a website.
Distribute everything that you write
that you want people to see
in as wide a range as possible.
Figure out who your audience is,
and the senior faculty
in your department
are not your audience, right?
When you come up for tenure,
it's not them that you
need to make happy -
it's everybody-it's everybody
outside of Harvard, right?
So it's your subfield
that's your audience.
When you give a talk,
I notice the three of us-
hold up-three of us prepare.
MICHELE:
We prepared.
So a lot of people on
conference presentations,
they view conferences
as commitment devices
to get themselves to work.
So they sign up for a conference
when they haven't
written a paper yet,
and that causes them to work
and they know that it
causes them to work.
And so then they'll-
finish the draft just
before the conference -
the draft, the first
draft of their paper.
And then when they're
appearing before people,
they'll sort of have a
lame version of the paper.
Don't just--don't do that.
Don't give a talk
at the first conference.
You just skip the first conference
of your whole career,
and then from then on,
give a talk about the paper
that was finished
four months before
and you have the final version.
And so every subsequent conference
across the rest of your career
you'll give the final--it doesn't
have to be the final paper.
You can change it if
you get some good ideas.
But it's a much more
professional paper.
In fact, if you write--if you get the
article accepted in the journal
and it's published in the
leading journal of your field,
it could be the case that
the total number of people
that read that is zero, right?
It could be the case.
It would not be-it will not
even be that big a surprise, okay?
But if you appear before
20 or 30 people and you talk,
they will remember who you are.
They will pay attention
for at least 10%
of what you're saying-
what you're talking about.
[Laughter]
Okay. So, also under
being a public figure,
you have to follow the rules
in a way that you've never
really had to follow the rules before.
Before, and as like a citizen,
you have to follow the
rules by making sure that,
like, you know what the law is and
you stay on the right side of the law,
okay? But that's not the rule here.
The rule as a public figure is
could there be an evil
reporter from The Boston Globe
who would write an article
about you and your research
that would ruin your career, okay?
And when they
come to you and say,
"Why did you do that?"
You had to have followed
all the rules, right?
So even if you know
that you don't have to go to
the institutional review board
to verify that your
human subjects research
is okay because you've done
this before and it's really okay -
if you didn't actually do it
and have the paper
trail that you did it,
then you can't say to the reporter
that you followed Harvard's rules.
So you have to do more.
It's actually the
appearance of impropriety
rather than impropriety.
And you have to be a
little obsessive about this.
Probably nothing's
going to happen
but to one of us
in this room it may,
so just be really careful.
You can have a blog
and you can--
I have a Twitter account,
kinggary, that's my Twitter.
And I tweet all the time.
You can find new papers
and new software that I write,
and you can even find out
about my mountain biking escapades.
But you're not going to
hear me arguing with my mom
or anything else I'm
not going to talk about.
So you just have to be careful.
And finally, in the second category,
don't let the fact
that you're a public figure
cause you to be unproductive.
I mean don't let the fact
that when you write something
and everybody - like, you know,
hundreds of people or
maybe thousands of people
and maybe even tens
of thousands of people
sometimes will see it -
don't let that stop you.
I mean you can learn in print
as much as you
can learn not in print.
You can learn even more in print
because people will come and
be in your face about things,
and you'll get feedback from a
much larger group of people.
So there's a syndrome
which I think of as the
dissertation award syndrome.
But it's probably
half of the people here
won an award for
the best dissertation.
And I'm always worried
about those people
because they think--
and I've seen this a lot,
they think that their next project…
I mean they just won the dissertation
award like of all the people,
of all the graduate students
in the whole country
and they got a job at Harvard.
The next project had better be really good.
So they're going to keep it
for a really long time, okay?
So that's the biggest mistake
you could possibly make, okay?
So it's much easier to correct
the problems in your paper
instead of--or your next work -
instead of by working on it
and working on it and working on it,
just do it, publish it.
And then choose the next project
so it doesn't have those
problems to begin with, right?
And then choose the next project.
The more chances you
have to do is the better.
Okay. Last point is
you have to organize your life, right?
You all realize that
compared to graduate school,
your income has now tripled
and your expenses
have quadrupled.
And so you have
to figure that out.
But you also have to
figure out the fact that
tenure--the joke is that
tenure is one-third teaching
and one-third service
and one-third research,
but really only the
last third counts.
But this is deeply not true.
And my point is not
"You should go put all your effort
into doing things
that aren't going to help you."
The point is that the people
who really figure out the system
are the ones who make all
three parts incentive compatible.
They make their teaching
compatible with their research.
They make service
to the University,
to the departments, or centers,
or events like this
relevant to what they're doing.
It's not easy but
that's really the goal.
I mean research is just a
measure of how you figured it out.
You have to teach.
You have to do some service.
You have to figure
out how to make that
serve your purposes
and at the same time serve
everybody else's purposes
because that's sort of, what
we're in the business of doing.
Psychologists say that
it takes 10,000 hours
of effortful study
to be the expert in a field.
And that takes a
lot of time obviously,
an enormous amount of time.
And so you just have
to look for synergies
and twofers and
making everyday life
into research projects.
You're also allowed
to have a life but
don't tell anybody
that we told you that.
So just two examples.
My speech to undergraduates
is that 99% of the faculty
don't actually come here
because they love teaching.
They may actually love teaching
but they're here because
research just wakes them up
every morning and
drives them to the office,
and makes them really
pursue new knowledge.
And it's just really the most
exciting thing on the planet.
And that's not a bad thing.
That's not bad that
we have this feeling.
I think instead of just saying
that that takes away from teaching,
we should just explain to students
that this is the most
exciting thing in the universe,
and get them involved
in your research.
So then it becomes…
It's just an example of how it
becomes incentive-compatible.
It's a travesty if a student
goes through four years
at Harvard University
and only learns about
discoveries in The Gazette, right?
That just should
never happen, right?
And you can change it.
You can change the
life of undergraduates,
which is a pretty cool thing to do,
and at the same time,
it can actually
help your research.
And it's the same for service,
the same for finding ways of
contributing to the centers
or to your departments or whatever.
But most importantly,
there's a lot of stress
and it's really hard
but it's a whole lot of fun.
So don't forget that part.
Okay. So
I guess I was going to first start
talking to you a little
bit about my trajectory
to tell you that I'm a
very unlikely person
to have ended up here.
But I think that if you
were to go around Harvard
and interview the faculty,
many people would tell
you exactly the same thing.
I think many, many people
end up being very surprised.
All this to say don't be
surprised that you're here.
Don't think that it's a university
that is more homogenous
than it is in reality.
As Gary said, we're
all here because in fact
we did things that were surprising.
The first
which means that what I did is
not generalizable in any way,
and you should indeed just
figure out your own path.
So I'm going to share a
few reflections with you
that are based on three things.
Since I started in my
role as a senior advisor
to Faculty Development Diversity,
I've been serving on the
Committee on Appointment,
Promotion, and FAS,
which means that all
the files that, are being
considered for tenure I have seen.
And I've learned a
lot about doing this,
and I've also in
the last few months
been very busy creating
a new mentoring program
for the junior faculty in FAS
which will be rolled out
in the next few weeks.
And you're going to
hear a lot about this.
So I've been thinking
about mentoring.
And finally,
I published last a year
a book entitled How Professors Think:
Inside the Curious
World of Academic Judgment,
which is the sociology of people
who sit on peer review panels
and how they go about
deciding who should be funded.
So really the question of the
legitimacy of our evaluation,
how we combine different criteria.
Those of you who feel very anxious
about the book should read it.
I think it would help
alleviate your concern.
So a few general lessons about--
that I've gained from my experience
in those various contexts.
The first one
which is a concept
that I had a problem
grasping the first time
I heard it when I was
Assistant Professor
at University of Texas at Austin,
a place where I felt
I didn't fit very well.
Nice thing about Harvard is
people like me who have accents;
everyone has an accent
here so it's really easy.
It's more cosmopolitan.
So first concept: Less is more.
Don't do too much, you know.
The people who get tenure
I think are people who develop
a distinct agenda-setting,
corpus of work
on a topic and a subfield.
So it's not about the
multiplication of papers
but it's about placing key papers
in places where they
can have an impact.
So from day one,
it's not Harvard that
gives you tenure -
it's the profession
that gives you tenure.
So you have to basically
not give them a choice
that I think is your point of departure -
you have to produce
so much good work
that even your worst enemies
will have problem writing
letters that are lukewarm.
They will look simply
foolish if they do it.
So all along, you have to engage
in conversation with
colleagues around the country
and beyond,
those who share your
intellectual concerns.
So you never should not
work for networking sake.
People hate that. It looks cheap.
What you should do is network
in such a way that you
follow your curiosity
and your need to engage
with people who share your interest.
And it's far more important I think
to be cosmopolitan than local;
that is it's far more important
to get people like UCLA
and Wisconsin to
know what you're doing
than your Fellow down the hall.
On the other hand,
the tenure process
requires all faculty members
in your department to
write a confidential letter,
at least that's how it works in FAS,
to your dean explaining
what they think of your work.
And that's a process where they
can qualify the yes/no vote
that they expressed
publicly in their department.
And, you know, these
letters are sometimes
five pages long so there's a
lot of room for qualifying.
So it's very important
in the seven years
that you're going to
share the life of this person,
that you give them
enough information
about the work that you
do that they can actually
write a letter that
is very well informed.
So that you kind
of help frame this letter,
not leave it to the three
days before the deadline
where he's going to sit
and discover your work.
All along you need to
engage your colleagues
in conversation about your work.
And not only
conversation about your work;
about their work.
People hate colleagues
who only care about themselves
so you really need to show,
and you need not only
to show but to be curious,
engage in other people's work.
Show that actually you're a
fun person to be around
as opposed to someone
who's very, very selfish
and not very
interested in others.
Now, what are the
contexts in which
you might want to
connect with others?
Luckily, Harvard
has so many resources
that it gets all of us exhausted.
Those of us who do work
in various areas of the world,
you have research
centers that organize--
that have resources for
you to organize colloquium,
to organize conferences.
You engage in conversation
by being involved in such things.
If you do international work,
the Weatherhead Center
has wonderful grants
that they make
available to junior people
so that you can bring to campus
experts in your field that will
discuss your book manuscript.
The junior faculty
with whom I've developed
relationships over the years
are people who have organized
symposiums where they've
asked me to participate.
And then I became more
aware of what they were doing
and then there was
a panel on their book
where I was asked to serve.
So really conversations that
develop over several years.
There are resources at Radcliffe.
I mean of course we
face a financial crisis
but the graduate
school offers small grants,
$2000, $3000 for
graduate students
to organize ongoing seminars,
and they generally have a faculty member
that initiates those things.
So this is money
that is extremely easy
to obtain and
it's a way to assemble
around new graduate students
and to invite people
from campus to give talks.
Another piece of advice
would be something like
be local
but to the extent that
you want to enjoy Harvard.
It is simply an extraordinary place.
I mean we're all maniacs.
No one has time.
But you kind of
have to make time
to enjoy the people
that share your interest.
Truly it's a source of pleasure
so you want to think of
Harvard not only as a source of stress
but also as offering
so many temptation
that you can barely
contain yourself.
Teaching is important
but it's a necessary but
insufficient condition for tenure.
And I think, you know, that's really…
it's very important
to keep this in mind.
You don't want to
over invest in teaching
to the extent that it will take
time away from your research.
You want to do it well
but you should absolutely
not over invest in it.
That's a mistake.
Service is very important
to the extent that it's a context
in which to develop bonds
and learn about the
organizational culture.
It also gives you a buffer
when you get tired
of your department,
when you get tired of the
politics of your department.
So don't be a prisoner of
your departmental politics.
Don't think about it too much.
There's not much
you can do about it
So keep your nose clean,
deliver the merchandise,
and develop ties
across all the units that are
relevant for your work
whether within FAS or beyond.
And most importantly,
don't forget to get your work done.
That's the most
important thing of all.
There's a recent book
titled How to Write A Lot,
which I'm giving to
my graduate students
when they get the book
they know they're in trouble.
[Laughter]
You can get it for $8 on Amazon.
And what it
recommends is simply
schedule regular writing time.
I'll give you one to exercise.
You don't want to
deliberate every morning
"Am I going to get on my--
am I going to exercise
this morning or not"
You just get up and do it.
Same thing with writing.
Do not give yourself a context
where you have to
deliberate about it each time.
You just have to create
automatism and do it in a very…
And finally, last
point - be resilient.
It's a world…
One of the previous
speakers was mentioning
that she's a former
competitive athlete,
and I was talking
recently with someone
who got tenure In FAS this year.
And she was telling me "The one
thing that served me best
is that I used to be a
competitive soccer
player at the national level."
You just have to be able
to prepare yourself to
absorb all the shocks.
I mean there's not
a single person
who's here within
the tenured rank
who's not awfully
resilient emotionally.
And, you know, indeed
we've all had rejections.
You can crawl in a corner and cry
or you can regroup yourself.
You know, people who
specialize in mental health
show having social
support is crucial.
One of the pieces of the
developmental networks
that we're going to--
the mentoring initiative
that we're about to roll out
is peer to peer mentoring.
Create a network of people
with whom you can commiserate
and get advice on how to deal
with the difficult graduate students.
Once you figure
out in your department
"Everyone thinks
this person is difficult,"
it makes your life much easier.
So the circulation of information
is absolutely important.
And also don't spread
yourself too thin.
To conclude, less is more.
Think very strategically about
how you're going to use this
unbelievable-the more-the
scarcest resource at Harvard
is time
and you have to think very carefully
about how you're going to invest it.
So that's it.
Okay.
Well, it's…
I was happy when
I got this invitation
because I'm now
in my 20th year here.
And I think every seven years
I get invited to speak
on this side of the river.
And I'm always scared
I won't get invited back
[Laughter]
because the myth is that
all the brilliant people
are on this side of the river.
So as I thought
about my remarks,
I realized that my
remarks are relevant
perhaps to only a minority
of those of you in the room.
But you're an important minority,
you're one that I belong to,
and that is those of us who
are not natural geniuses.
[Laughter]
Okay? Those of us who wind
up here by dint of some combination of
passion, hard work, finding
that one thing in the world
that we do seem to be
sort of a bit more
gifted than others.
But we know it's not just pure genius,
all right, because the geniuses,
you know, they will go and
they'll look at what Gary's done
and they'll just create
their version of it.
They don't have to think about it,
right, and they'll be successful.
But others of us
have to actually build careers.
And so my advice is aimed
toward that set of you.
And, you know, and I
was thinking about advice
that I've gotten over
the course of my career,
and I remember
one piece of advice that I found
totally useless and intimidating,
and that was when I sat down
with the guy who
was the Senior Associate
dean for recruiting like I was.
And he says to me, "You know,
we like research with impact."
He read my mind and he said,
"I can't tell you what it looks like
but I can tell you we know
it when we see it". He told me this.
Another piece of advice I got
that actually was
sort of, like a parable
that I've actually said
to junior faculty
at the Business School and
I just say just meditate on it.
And it was that "The
secret to getting ahead
at the Harvard Business School
is to create a game--
make up the rules so that
you can teach them to other people,
so that when they apply the rules,
they arrive at the conclusion
that you are the best person
playing that game and that
it is a game worth playing."
So he says this
to me and, you know,
it's kind of like a parable, like
"What are you talking about?"
[Laughter]
But, if you--
I thought about it and as I've
said it to other junior faculty
and I said "Just think about it."
A number of times
people have come to me
after their Associate's promotion or
just as they're coming
up for tenure and they said
"I finally got it".
And what it is about
is creating a game,
which means sort of
figuring out what it is
that you're doing
and where it fits in the world
and what the rules
are that you're playing by,
but the requirement is
that you have to be able to
teach them to other people
so they know what
game you're playing.
If you're playing by a game
governed by a set of rules that
nobody else can understand,
the likelihood
that you'll be able to
be judged and deemed
as meeting the criteria that,
I think, we want you to
meet here at Harvard
or at least in the context of
Harvard that I'm familiar with -
which is that you're
doing something
that is worthy of being done
in the world and we can
all agree that that's worthy.
And oftentimes though
when you started,
we don't actually know what
the game is you're playing.
Right? And you've got
to figure that out,
sort of what the purpose
is that your work is serving
and why it's important.
And then at the end of the day,
you have to be okay with the fact
that other people are
going to apply those rules
and arrive at the conclusion
whether or not you're the
best person in the world playing it.
I think it's also…
And that also speaks to the
fact that it does start with the work.
And the points that
Gary and Michele made
that were very specific about
things to do to advance the work,
I think, are right on the money.
The thing I also think is important
is that at some point in your
career as you're engaging
in this process - and I used
the term sort of "playing this game,"
not in a pejorative sense
of the game that we're
somehow being dishonest
but that this is our life
but it's not all of our life a
nd we should be enjoying it -
is to make sure that
your work gives
you a chance to win
in this environment
on terms that you value.
And by winning what I mean is
that you can fulfill your purpose
and also have a
successful career here.
When I talk to junior faculty
who sort of complain about
some of the things you have to do
to be successful, I kind of say,
"Well, you have to
decide whether or not
you can do what you want to do
on the terms that are required
and still have the
possibility of winning."
So it starts with the work
and those are the comments
I would say about the work.
I would also underscore
that if it starts with the work
then the next most
important thing is the relationships.
And Michele talked about
the efforts that are underway
to make mentoring more accessible,
and more visible and
transparent in the environment.
I talk about that both
in my work as well as,
in my academic work as well as
my work as a Department Chair
from the vantage point of
creating a developmental network.
And we use this
term "network," right,
and it can mean lots of things.
But what I would
ask you think about is
do you have a
developmental network?
Which means a set of people
with whom your interactions
prepare you for
the next opportunities
that you can't see.
And a network that allows you
to find ways to connect
who you are with what you do.
And I'll give you an example of
that connection from my own.
I started my career
at the Wharton School.
Senior faculty would
come and see me teach
when we first get there--
make sure you're not doing
damage to the tuition paying clients.
And they come back
and they give me advice,
and they pulled back…
This is back when we had overheads.
Pulled back the projector,
take up the entire screen,
walk around the room.
And if they had come
back a week or two later
they would never have predicted
that I would be where I am today,
seen as a relatively
competent teacher,
et cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
Because I was getting
all these great advice
but executing that advice,
given who I was
standing in that classroom
was extremely difficult, right?
And I developed a
relationship with one person
who I could talk to about
what it was like to be me
trying to execute on that advice.
The experience,
not just the what, right?
Like you can go and
you ask people what to do,
they tell you what to do,
you walk out and you say
"I can never do that."
But you need some
people to whom you can say
"I feel like I could never do that"
who will support you in
the experiment of doing it.
Because the way we
learn professional roles
is through experimentation.
None of us were born professors, right?
So we've got to create
a set of experiments
to figure out how I can
successfully take on that role.
If you don't have a set of
people with whom you can talk about
those experiments,
then when you feel
like you're failing,
you will start to fall.
And the fear
shouldn't be of failing -
the fear should be of falling.
By falling, what I mean
is you just feel down
and it becomes hard to get up
and suddenly you're not visible.
Third thing.
So relationships is two.
The third thing that I would say
is important is figuring out
how to manage your time
and create leverage.
I think the first piece of
managing your time effectively
is what Gary referred to,
is what I would call
creating the synergy
between these
requirements of teaching
and research and service.
I also think figuring out how to,
early in your career,
how to use resources that
are available - research assistants.
At Harvard Business
School were lucky.
We can supply people
research assistants
relatively early on and they
don't have to go get an NIH grant
or anything like that
before they can have one.
I see junior faculty
become Associate Professors
before they actually learn
how to leverage that resource.
And figuring out likewise
with library resources,
and sort of figuring
out how over time
you are always
applying your time
to the places where
you add the most value.
And some of that
requires letting go.
Like you don't have
to code all the data
like you did when you
were a graduate student.
Part of it, you know,
connecting to undergrads
in the way that Gary described,
is that things that are no longer
actually value added for you to do,
it's real value added
for undergrads,
or your students who you
might work with who feel,
get invested in the process
of creating the discovery.
And also I think
figuring out how to create
mutually beneficial relationships
with doctoral students
that are not exploitive,
because if you
become an exploiter
that becomes known.
And sooner or later
you pay a price
for it, in my view.
And sadly enough
there are people who
have exploitive relationships
with doctoral students.
In some departments,
it's part of the culture.
So if it was done to
you, don't repeat it.
The last thing…
Sorry if my talk is
sounding like a downer.
[Laughter]
But Gary had us all laughing
and now I'm looking at people's
faces and they're like "Damn."
[Laughter]
Okay.
So in which case, here's
the up one, final thing -
I think it's important to
focus on your mental health.
The place is stressful.
I love the comment that the
woman on the last panel said
her parents ask her
"What do you have to do?"
and she says, "You've
just got to be great."
There's some truth to that sense.
You just have to be great.
And you look around
and you see people who,
God damn it, they look great.
[Laughter]
I was sitting here and Eliza was
reading Gary's bio and I was thinking,
"Damn, I'm glad I'm on the
other side of the river.
I'd hate to see him every day."
[Laughter]
So don't deny the stress.
But again I think to this
point of our relationships,
you need some places where
you can admit to it and let it go.
I also think it's important to
develop some life beyond your work -
some things you do that you
value that are rejuvenating,
Otherwise, the only
measure of yourself
is the measure that's
made of you here.
And again, this is for
those of you like me
who are not geniuses:
I can tell you there are
many days when the measure
of me here is much shorter
than I think I should be.
And being able
to go somewhere else
where there are things
that remind me
that this is not the only measure
is important to
keeping that balance
and reconnecting in a way
that allows me to rise to the
measure that I think I can rise to.
And then the final thing I think is
it's very important to
keep your priorities clear
and to understand that
how you allocate your time
usually does not
reflect your priorities.
So there's no question in my mind
that my family is my first priority.
But my wife and I
would argue about this -
I would say that I allocate
about 80/20 work, family, my time.
She would probably say
that 20 is a bit high.
[Laughter]
But I'm clear about the priorities.
And I think it's often important
to create some rules
that allow you to
force those choices.
And I'll just end with
one story about myself,
and that is when I was
coming up for tenure
I made one promise to myself,
and that is that
to get tenure
I would not refuse
to do anything
that if after the decision
was made and it was negative,
I would regret
having not done that
because I paid a price for something
that ultimately I didn't get.
And having made that rule,
you know, when it
was easy to make it
because I didn't
have any forced choices
and everybody was on board -
even my daughter
was editing my book.
She was only six years old,
she'd come in at night…
Everybody was on board
for me to be 90% at work.
"You have a six-year-old
daughter and Michele,
they're like six years old
and this guy gets tenure?"
But anyway, yes,
she's brilliant.
But anyway,
my mother was coming.
My mother usually
comes for Mother's Day.
And my wife said
"Tell your mother don't come
because you're right in the
middle of writing this book,"
and it turned out that I had
to turn this book around
really quick to make the deadline.
And I decided no,
I'm going to have my
mother come because
if my mother - if something
were to happen,
my mother wouldn't be there
and I didn't get tenured,
I would regret it.
But having those…
And mind you,
what happened was
my mother came,
we had a great time,
gave me the energy,
I finished the book.
But it's like having those things
that force you in some way
to keep your priorities clear,
because your time
won't always reflect
them so you can lose them
I think becomes key as
part of this sort of
keeping your mental
health and your balance.
So I'll end there.
You guys got any jokes
so I can get the…
[Laughter]